hey my name is Samuel Leeds and on this
video I want to talk about mortgage
holiday payments this is something that
pretty much all lenders are doing they
announced this last week and they're
saying that you do not have to pay your
mortgage payments for three months now
have I taken advantage of that should
you take advantage of that what exactly
does it mean what are the catches that
is what I'm going to be talking about on
this video so first let me just explain
this whilst the lender is saying you
don't have to pay your mortgage for
three months it is not free money so you
will have to pay the money back at some
point what most lenders are doing is
they're putting let's say your mortgage
payments at the moment of 500 pounds per
month and that could be a buy-to-let
property or a property that you live in
so if you're paying farm depan a month
on the mortgage and you say actually I'm
gonna take advantage of the holiday
three-month period then 1500 pounds I
need three months mortgage payments you
will have to pay you that's pet all in
one go what most lenders are doing is
they're adding it on to the total
outstanding mortgage so you what will
happen is after three months or however
long the period is that you I mean
somebody in more than three months but
you'll just end up paying a little bit
more each month thereafter so that's
what it is now when it first came out
when they first announced this last week
and they all said that there were they
were doing this to help because of the
coronavirus I wasn't sure who would
qualify and exactly how easy it was
because it said that it was a
case-by-case basis which it is and it
depends on the individual and there was
lots of different circumstances so I
wanted to hold off doing this video
because I want to see how feasible it is
to see if people actually are getting it
to also see if it affects your credit or
not and it looks like it is happening
I've seen a lot of people that have done
it I've qualified for it it might take a
few days but it is a real thing and
there doesn't seem to be too many
strings attached over the fact that
they're going to put the money onto the
existing loan have I done it I'll get
there in a minute in a moment and let me
talk about the pros first and then I'll
talk about the cons so the pros are cash
flow if you are absolutely strapped
right now or if you've got tenants not
paying rent or if you've got a mortgage
which you physically can
pay 100% you should you should do the
holiday free period because it's much
better to get a three month grace period
that you just physically not be able to
pay it and then end up damaging your
credit and so so I would definitely
suggest doing it so I guess the pros are
the only pro is cashflow you're not
being free my name you're not gonna be
any richer because of it you're just
gonna have you're just gonna have a
situation whereby you have a little bit
of relief over these few months so
that's the pro the con is that your
interest payments are gonna go up after
the three-month period it they are
saying that it's not gonna affect your
credit that's what most lenders are
saying but every lender is a little bit
different and there are some lenders
that have said it shouldn't affect your
credit much basically so I don't think
it will affect your credit it certainly
isn't going to absolutely blacklist you
but there's always a chance I mean I my
decision is because I haven't got
massive cash flow issues right now and
because I want to have the best credit I
possibly can because it's important as a
property investment developer even
though they're saying it's not going to
fit your credit I have chosen not to
have a three-month holiday period on my
mortgages for the reason that I don't
feel like I need to it's not free money
and I just want to make sure that my
cash flow is sorry that my credit is as
good as it can be so I haven't done it
should you do it I guess it's your call
speak to your lender if you have any
specific requests because as I say each
lender is this is case-by-case depending
on the individual depending on the
lender so that's all it is it's very
very very simple and I hope that answers
some questions to you guys so good luck
standing with you and I think my next
whole bunch of videos over these two
weeks he's just gonna be about helping
you in this situation because I know
it's crazy time we're in lockdown I
haven't even got my like video crew
around or anything so I'm just shooting
this off my iPhone in my bedroom but if
there's any specific content that you
want to see if you've got any specific
fears over this virus and over this lock
down then comment below and I'm going to
do my best to tailor the video
specifically to you to your questions to
your fears to your needs in
difficult time so thank you for watching
smash the like button if you enjoyed the
video and if you didn't enjoy the video
then smash the dislike but but it does
the exact same thing for the YouTube
algorithm so I'm all good but do
something and if you're not subscribe
please do subscribe I also did a video
about tenants if you're concerned about
tenants not paying rent and you can
check that video out right about here
subscribe over here and I'll see you on
the next video thanks so much god bless